اكبر تحديدا لامني واستقرار المنطقه ياتي
من ايران وبشكل واضح وموفق هكذا تقول
الولايات المتحده ووجهه التحديد ام متنوعه
النووي بالطبع موجود مجلس محافظين وكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه طالب بالتعاون بشان
تحقيقات اثار اليورانيوم ومياه الخليج جزء
اخر من هذا التهديد ولا دليل على ذلك اكبر
من هجمات المستمره اخرها استهدفت ناقله
نفطن قبله عمان ولاجل هذا الامر ولاجل هذه
التحديثات تحضر القرارات الامريكيه قوه
مخصصه للانظمه غير الماهوله في الخليج
القوه 59 التي اعلن عنها الاصول الخامس في
سبتمبر الماضي العام الماضي ستنشره اكثر
من 100 سفينه مسيره في مياه المنطقه
الاستراتيجيه بحلول العام المقبل
ديسباسيتو
القرصنه تجاره البشر الهجمات على السفن
التجاريه والتهريب اكان تهريب سلاح او
مخدرات واكثر تحديدا على المنطقه هي بشكل
واضح وموفق ايران
وكلاء اضافه طبعا لمشروعها النووي
كره هذه التهديدات الايرانيه فكان يجب ان
تكون المواجهه استثنائيه القوه 59 هي اول
قوه من نوعها تابعه للبحريه الامريكيه
تدمج الانظمه غير الماهوله والذكاء
الصناعي بسرعه مع العمليات البحريه
للاسطول الخامس وهو الذي يغطي ما يقرب من
مليونين و500,000 ميلا مربع تشمل الخليج
العربي وخليج عمان البحر الاحمر واجزاء من
المحيط الهندي منطقه
21 الدوله و3 نقاط حرجه في مضيق هرمز قناه
السويس وماضي قبل المنزل
فقد استخدمت المسيررات ومن خلال
التكنولوجيا التي كانت تنشرها في المنطقه
فانها تتسبب بحاله من عدم الاستقرار وهو
ما يشكل مصدر قلق كبير لنا لكن لحسن الحظ
في هذا الهجوم ما من شخص قد اصيب وفي
حقيقه امر فانه في العام الماضي وتحديدا
في شهر يوليو تعرض شخصان كان على متن احدى
السفن للقتل بهجوم مشابه لذا هذه العمليات
لابد ان تتوقف ولهذا السبب فاننا ملتزمون
بالحفاظ على حضور بحري مستمر مع شركائنا
في المجال البحري